what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series where we do reactions
that do not take things out of contact
and spin a false narrative like a lot of
these fake news reaction channels that
just spin their narrative regardless of
the facts today I'm gonna be talking
about all of this nonsense that we have
seen on Twitter nonsense nonsense
nonsense so pull the clips King before I
start guys don't forget like the video
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell oh this one okay let
me I'm gonna have to read this one
because this is crazy in today's news a
republican city council member in
Indiana that came out as a black woman
of color earlier this month is now
receiving death threats from far left
activists and Council community members
over his Newfound identity King why
would they shame him for his new
identity you don't I don't know
Delaware's counts Delaware County
Councilman Ryan Webb made the
announcement on a Facebook post on April
12. where he stated that with all of the
Newfound genders and self-identities in
the world today he finally feels
comfortable and living his life in his
true authentic self isn't that great for
him yeah yeah and this is a quote from
him after much consideration I have
decided to come out and I finally feel
comfortable announcing my true authentic
self it is with great relief that I
announced to everyone that identify as a
woman and not just any woman but a woman
of color as well I guess that would make
me gay and lesbian since I am attracted
to women Webb said on Facebook I'm
excited to bring some diversity to the
County Council until today we didn't
have any females of color or
lgbtqia PC Plus Plus on the council I'm
glad that we do web continued to avoid
confusion everyone can continue to
address me as Ryan or councilman Webb
and I will also retain my preferred
pronouns of he him however this will in
no way diminish my true identity as a
woman of color I'm excited to be a vocal
partner of the
lgbtqia PC plus plus movement who knows
just how far we can take things but I'm
glad that this is now possible so anyone
can be anything or anyone they want
webro calling out the hypocrisy of the
alphabet Warriors Webb concluded the
post saying it has come to my attention
that I am more than likely the first
lesbian woman of color in the history of
Delaware County to ever serve on our
Delaware County Council I am honored to
have been the one to have shattered that
glass ceiling to no surprise at all
Webb's announcement has sparked
significant backlash towards the
tolerant members of his community which
resulted in them lining up one by one at
the city council meeting on Tuesday
calling for his resignation why would he
have to resign he's being his true self
that's what they want I I'm good to
start identifying as a bad bee and get
into places for free
you're right you're right I want to
identify as Beyonce because I just think
I would do well in life if I was Beyonce
she's married to a billionaire you know
what I mean she's got like four kids
she's got it all so I'm like I identify
I am now Beyonce if he were serious I'd
sing his Praises Charlize Jameson a
trans-identified man said at the meeting
according to munchie Star Press but
instead I know better we all do I know
because of his history of making
anti-trans statements on social media
disrespecting one's pronouns he has
purposely and intentionally misgendered
me ridiculing my own identity that's not
something transgender people do to each
other when it was Webb's turn to address
the community which consisted mostly of
outraged liberal white women now I'm not
going to say that women are the the
problem with these movements now I
wouldn't say that that would be super
sexist to say that like women push these
movements it's not the men it's women
that co-sign on these craziness you know
there's some men but those men are
really pandering to the women you know I
mean come on they're just trying to get
laid or whatever I wouldn't say that
that would be sexist but I may imply it
I might you know what I mean I might
imply it a little bit no okay sorry I'll
continue the article he after they were
left shocked after he refused to bow to
the far left mob and slammed them for
having the audacity to question his new
identity oh
wait click the article click the article
because the picture of the women that
are pissed is so funny oh my gosh this
is so funny you don't get to question me
you don't get to require proof from me
scroll down yeah so that right there
that's the trans person that was
questioning um his identity which is
very rude we don't question identities
here rolls clip of me calling the trans
person a man okay okay sometimes
sometimes we do but this person I would
not I would not do that would be so rude
but continue continue yeah these are the
look at them look at look at it look how
mad they are this is an owl for women
like this is just an owl ladies why why
why would you do this now okay I'm just
gonna read this man's quote I'm gonna
continue I'm sorry I'm sorry I get
distracted guys you don't get to
question me you do not get to require
proof for me you are part of this
movement that helped establish these
rules and set the bar okay you don't get
to come later when someone else joins
the club that you don't want in you
don't get to question how I identify
website according to the munchy Star
Press shortly after the meeting Webb
made a follow-up Facebook post which
indicated that his decision to change
identities worked out as planned people
don't get it they're speaking out
publicly about the obvious contradiction
and ideology web wrote further
fortunately for myself I have received
positive messages of support have far
outweighed the negative thank you for
your support but much to his dismay Webb
is now a target of political violence
from the far left activists in his
community who are refusing to accept his
new identity release the statement to
wishtv.com which revealed that
Progressive groups have started to
organize hate and harassment campaigns
against his family and have gone as far
as publishing his home address online
this is what happened I attacked the
whale Community once and they came for
me and were trying to dox me too this is
what they do our family has been
receiving violent death threats that's
what they did to me too the whales the
way it's like you right throughout the
day from intolerant liberals who refuse
to accept my decision to live my life
however I choose Webb told the outlet
it's unfortunate but a group called
Indiana progressives has decided to
organize a Hayden harassment campaign
against me and my family by publishing
my address and encouraging people to
lawfully congregate at my home you can
look at their comments on my public post
I have to look out for the safety of my
family including our six children these
are people with serious mental health
issues encouraging people who are
unwelcome to come to my home it is
unfortunate that I cannot be simply
given the space and respect to explore
my identity that so many of the
targeting that of those targeting me
demand for themselves I have announced
my position and that has not changed I
have recently decided to live my life
however I choose to identify which
happens to be as a woman of color my
American Indian Heritage is not up for
debate although many would like to be no
no he did not do that he pulls it
Elizabeth Warren I may change my mind
down the road the process of my identity
exploration is complex and often times
at the end of our personal Journey we
end up right where we start right back
where we started I hope that in the
future those asking for tolerance and
understanding are willing to give it in
return and not just to those who they
feel are worthy of it nobody has the
authority to invalidate to validate or
invalidate any individuals who chooses
to identify a certain way well I think
this was inspirational don't you I
didn't realize that it's okay to not
believe people's self-identification
yeah I didn't know that yeah I thought
we were supposed to believe women and
since he's a woman yeah
you know believe all women lady come on
now now many people were offended by
this but I'm not I think he should be
able to identify as he sees fit so in
other news Andrew Tate has been fighting
The Matrix so he as you guys know when
he was arrested which they still haven't
charged him with a crime after detaining
him for months and then and then
throwing him in uh prison and now he's
on house arrest
um they also took his sports cars can
you imagine working your whole life and
the government can just take away your
cars when they see fit um so uh Andrew
decided um roll the clip to fight the
matrix by
they took all my cars he called took all
my car so I bought 10 Bugattis look
what's the logo
see at the next house raid
and now I'm the fastest man in the world
he has such a good attitude about
everything
about 10 Bugattis get on one Let's Race
I remember the fastest man in the world
how long until default Raiders take our
guys away hahaha
yeah
that's funny that was funny I wanna I
wanna race in one yeah I should buy a
Bugatti we could do it around the
penthouse
uh let's let's not get carried away
I
don't like on Twitter also on Twitter
sneak
sneak show and has been mercilessly
attacked I am so tired of them attacking
sneak out attacking fresh and fit and
spinning A Narrative of things that
these guys don't say and that's what we
see with the fake news reaction Channel
media all right all of these fake
narrative spinning reaction channels
none of them have live shows and let me
tell you what's important to know about
having a live show anybody that has a
live show knows that at some point
you're gonna say something off some
point you're gonna contradict yourself
uh because these reaction channels don't
have a message they don't stand for
anything they don't believe anything and
they're just the TMZ of YouTube how
credible is TMZ as a source do we do we
take their word as gospel but for some
reason we take reaction channels of
people that sit in their rooms and
stream or you know sit on a squeaky
floor back up dancers we did
we take their opinion seriously and this
is why it's important to think about who
are you listening to and the thing about
snico is you could see in front of your
eyes the message that he's spreading
like and the changes he's making in his
life and how it's impacting him like he
was a liberal a couple years ago and now
he's a conservative and you can see or
more conservative or Brad pill right but
and you can see how it changes him like
he's in better shape he's not in this
crazy one-sided open like this open
relationship weird stuff you know and
you can see how it's positively
impacting him where the reaction
channels that a lot of people are
listening to you look at the impact over
years they're in worse shape they're not
in stable or an admirable relationships
and you could see how a negative message
like impacts you long term and again a
lot of these reaction channels take
Clips they sit on they sit on your live
streams waiting for something they can
take out of context to spin a narrative
so here's an example
um that snico talks about he says every
one of my haters addresses me as an
alpha male as a shaming tactic I'm not
going to say that's what modern women do
but some of these men are acting like
modern women with their gossip channels
following the drama you could say that
maybe I'm following the drama but I'm a
woman we expect that from women we don't
expect that from grown adults okay now
sunico says I have never called myself
that nor do I believe that to be true
yet young women are encouraged to be
independent Boss [__] Queens when a
young man values those qualities in
himself he is mock how many men do you
think gave up their pursuit of strength
and wealth how many chose weakness to
fit their agenda I refuse to lose and I
think this is a really really good point
how it's like whenever a man does
anything masculine or takes pride in
being masculine we shame him men that
are pursuing you know women money perpet
like whatever whatever they care about
any guy that's trying to better himself
is shame yeah we put on a pedestal the
TMZ channels of YouTube that stand for
nothing believe nothing and don't have a
message and that really just argue and
the crazy thing is you guys are going to
start to notice this they argue with
both sides and they don't have a point
for example one may say getting divorced
over chores is bad and they'll argue no
it's not that bad and then you might say
well okay is it a good thing and they'll
say well they won't go that far either
they're just professional fence sitters
and they don't pick a side they don't
stand for anything they don't believe in
anything they don't have a message and
if you listen to people like that too
long enough and deem their opinions as
credible to be honest it just allows
like people that historically never
would have had an opinion or a say to
have an opinion or an opinion and a site
when really they're gossipy and they're
they're the TMZ channels of YouTube so
you know do it this what you want you
know maybe I'm wrong let me know in the
comments but that's just my opinion so
next all right oh Andrew Tate tweeted oh
this was so money he says listen to
Grandma Cinderella removed one shoe and
she found love y'all girls out here half
naked and still single
yeah what's what's the top comment read
it what's the top comment
um social media I can't read it's too
small what does it say social media
changes our mindset as girls that we
need to go to the extreme length to
compete with other girls for men every
day there is something new we need to
change in our appearance in order to
remain attractive to men that's the top
comment quit whining I'm so tired of
these whiners
one said I'm half naked and still get
any boy I want to literally anyone it's
such a cope
hey girl that I know that says I get
every boy I want does not in fact get
every man she wants like like literally
uh like if you really had the man you
want would you be putting that on social
media would you be having to come it's a
cope it's a cope because if you had the
quality of men interested in you like
the women I know that actually when I
think of there was this girl I went to
college with okay and this girl she just
killed the game you know what I mean she
was just genuinely a nice person and she
would always be in long-term
relationships and the second she got out
of one there would be a line of men
waiting and it wasn't like she was super
hot she was she was cute but she was
just genuinely like a really nice kind
caring compassionate person you can't
fake that and she didn't have to go
around telling everybody that that she
got the quality of men that she wanted
because like she I don't even think she
ever mentioned it to be honest because
it just came so naturally to her my what
is my point in this the women that get
the men they want don't talk about
getting the men they want because they
it just it just happens I think she's
engaged now actually yeah you know she
she wins in life okay uh oh okay that's
what is the caption to this one what
does it say yeah okay so this is from
the FG House Bunny I couldn't watch it
they annoyed me hundreds of stupid young
women exposing themselves as such
ill-informed and uneducated they're like
this on the internet someone needs to
tell them they don't look powerful or
strong just stupid oh also dangerous to
men in society so oh this is from like a
pro-life Mart so it's always the most
reasonable women you know that show up
to these pro pro choice I get to kill my
babies March do you know how crazy you
gotta be to like to be that passionate
about killing your child I'm just like
how many abortions have you had do you
know what I mean like to to go to the
point where you gotta go to these
marches like are you doing this every
year is this is this a common occurrence
for you
um but let's let's let's see the the
super reasonable women in
words
the rapists The Grapist is you the
murderer is you so this seems like a
very efficient way to get things done to
just go there and tell men that they're
rapists and murderers I'm sure if the
women had that happen to them they would
be super reasonable and understanding
when when you think about it who's the
real murderers I mean I'm not the one
killing the kids could you argue that
they're murderers yeah okay play it play
it
[Applause]
I'm sorry about this this is just giving
like Nazi Vibes man yeah and even I was
thinking like say it like cold so weird
oh
everybody
[Applause]
wait wait and our punishment is ongoing
violence
is that a bit ironic when they're the
ones promoting violence like we have an
abortion like they literally pull have
you ever seen an abortion really I'm
surprised but for those of you that
don't know they literally
um and especially if it's a surgical
abortion like if you take the pill one
it basically starves the child and it
comes out of like you know down and like
I had a girl on the show that said she
didn't realize when she had an abortion
how like formed the child was and the
other way you can do it is they
literally pull off the limbs one by one
they crush the skull and then they
vacuum it out so you're saying that
they're the violent ones but you're the
one signing up to do that it's crazy
because I don't know about here but back
in Nigeria
this is something I know I like I
actually know that this has happened
some because some girls can't afford
to do actual abortions or maybe they
can't find the doctor that can do it for
them there are some girls that used to
use like
um do you know these old clothes hangers
that are made of like wire ew
bend it and put it in there and
literally scrape it out themselves you
know 97 of abortions are elective like
they have no reason to get them it's
just and that's the thing it's like guys
can we just make better choices as women
you can only really get pregnant a
couple days of the month like because
they'll always say I don't want to be on
birth control but I'm like why don't you
track when you're ovulating like oh no
that's too hard what the why do you work
Honda it's like condoms then no no they
never want to wear them I'm like well
you could still buy it
crazy women
she called a fan side impunity for my
murderer you're the but you're the
murder what
are they squatting I mean if this is
what it takes to get women to work out
then we might have to support this
no
why would you do that but I'm like are
they squatting like why are they
squatting
[Music]
[Applause]
that one in the front she needs to squat
a bit more you know
just exercise that lady's gotten all
month
of where I was or how I was dressed oh I
hate that argument that oh well if you
say hey maybe don't put yourself in
certain situations they act like like
they act like you're victim like you're
victim blaming when it's like if you're
gonna give advice to someone you love
would you not tell them to maybe avoid
situations where strange men like
there's some times where there's nothing
you can do right if someone breaks into
your house and does that like what what
were you supposed to do but would you
encourage women to put locks on their
doors would you encourage women to not
walk around half naked in the middle of
the night wouldn't you encourage women
to not get super black out drunk you
know it's just like what are we pushing
and then this is what the fence sitters
will do the fence sitters will say well
that's not really fair women should be
able to walk how they want and you could
be like well shouldn't is is very
different
um and if you're gonna give advice to a
girl why would you not tell her to be as
safe as possible
a lot of women like to approach this
sort of arguments from an idealistic
point of view forgetting that we live in
the real world meaning there's always
going to be criminals there's always
going to be rapists there's always going
to be murderers so it's like me saying
oh I should be able to walk outside in
the middle of the night on my own with a
gold chain worth five million dollars
and no one should rob me
yes no one should but more than likely
someone is going to yeah and if I say
hey maybe don't walk home alone at night
that's how I was well attacked tell the
whale have you ever seen my whale attack
video yeah yeah it's like it just acts
like that's crazy
[Applause]
wasn't mine if it's my body my choice
wouldn't you be to blame if it was your
choice
[Applause]
the guilty party is not me oh by the way
I have you see this thing about clothes
that women wear I have a very big
argument against it because women keep
saying well I should be able to wear
what I want but there's a reason why it
is a saying called dress how you wish to
be addressed there's a reason why if you
dress like a bomb people are going to
think of a bum there's a reason why if
you dress like if you wear a police
uniform people are going to think you're
a policeman
people are not going to see someone
wearing a police uniform and then or
somewhere like uh sorry what's it called
uh Builders uniform and expect him to go
and arrest the criminal no that's not
how it works so if you dress because you
see this thing fashion has what fashion
does it takes it takes Trends and makes
it into like it takes um sorry
um social constructs and mix it into
Trends so for instance there was a time
where sagging for guys was kind of like
trending but really and truly when
sagging was trending will you see CEOs
of like would you see Elon Musk sagging
his pants that's the point right so it's
kind of like women who say well I should
be able to do what I want so because
it's a trend for you to wear sloty
dresses doesn't mean you're gonna see uh
what's her name
um Obama's wife wearing Michelle Obama
and snapping [__] pictures yeah well
and it kind of shows you're a weak
person if you're just going with the
trends and what everyone else is doing
like that's the thing I just think like
character is so rare nowadays it's just
so much easier for people to just follow
the crowd and the trends and media nor
my clothes or where I was
foreign
state is a rapist Macho
[Applause]
who raises the rapist The Greatest Story
who raises the rapist single mothers
it's like you're I think it's like 80 or
80 times more likely to be a rapist if
you're raised by a single mom that's why
I say every problem in society is linked
to women breaking up families people
think I'm like hating on women but I'm
really hating on the Sims in a way that
accept this but because when you think
about it like all of these crime like
you're more likely to be homeless and
you're fear in a single mother home
you're more likely to be in prison
you're more likely to be a rapist you're
more likely to commit a crime like every
negative thing that can happen in
societies from being in a single mother
household so if the women are choosing
to leave like we're the ones ruining
Society in a way
um I even I spoke to there's a homeless
shelter you know down the street and I
talked to the guy that runs it for like
an hour and I was asking him like why
like because um I I didn't realize
there's different types of homeless like
there's homeless like living in a car
but the one that he does is like
homeless literally on the street like
that's that's the type he works with so
it's like the the least privileged I
guess type of homeless people and I
asked them like what what makes them end
up in these situations and he said like
the biggest thing is being in
Dysfunctional homes so they've never
learned any real life skills they've
never learned how to maintain
relationships so they just grow up in
this Society like completely lost
because they've been in foster care for
half their life because they were taken
from their mother who couldn't take care
of them at like three or whatever and so
then they just go from Foster Care
Family to foster care family and then
end up being like taken by the system
and now they're homeless so it's like
literally every problem in society is
linked to single mother homes I see I
was thinking about something pertaining
to women
I don't think it's really women's fault
the way like a lot of women behave
because if you think about it it's still
kind of linked to survival I think women
tend not to take hard stances on
polarizing views because
taking a hot stance could sometimes
affect survivability so women have to
kind of be very flexible
to be able to survive because if we were
to take it back to history if you're
away with like Chief if you're like a
chief and maybe he was like conservative
as a woman for you to be with him you
have to be conservative but then if like
some liberal Chief came and killed
the conservative men and took the women
then they will have to be liberal to
survive with the new guy
so it's kind of like it's almost like
women kind of have to be able to play
Both Sides to be able to survive which
is weird
because it's kind of like
then at the same time they want to still
have power
and at the same time they still want to
make decisions but then you're still the
person that would float on both sides of
defense well zeros are interesting when
men get power they try to do what's
right where women do what benefits them
because like men gave us the right to
vote because they thought it was the
right thing to do women as soon as we
got into Power where we're influencing
elections we just like we we took as
much power as we could and that's why we
haven't like a system I think that
oppresses man I Wanna Hold on I actually
want to find this tweet I don't know
where it is but it was basically this
Twitter thread that I was talking about
like the things that men and women do
when they get power but I mean I just
think if you incentivize women to make
poor decisions they probably will
um and I think when women get money if
they don't like their husband it's just
like I'm out especially when the
government like pays them to do it I
mean why why wouldn't you oh oh my gosh
shambles have you ever seen this show I
think it's called shambles let me let me
double check
um no it's not shambles
um oh Shameless Shameless that's what
it's called have you seen all right you
you have seem Shameless okay so all
right guys next on the Twitter files all
right Shameless is a Netflix show that's
really popular and it's actually based
on where I'm from which is Chicago and
it's essentially about these kids that
were are being raised in foster care
not really foster care like they
basically have a deadbeat mom and a
deadbeat dad and the oldest sister takes
care of everybody
um and it goes through like the trials
and tribulations of the family and it's
really popular among like younger people
and this is the problem that we get with
Netflix trying to promote an agenda now
you might say that the Netflix slash
reaction Channel slash fake news media
is unbiased but you tell me you tell me
King let me know if you would want your
daughter to watch this show are you
ready I'm a tri-racial cisgendered
growth act I identify as 10 seconds
okay
hey Emerson gender fluid heteroromantic
demisexual Mutt and a redhead my pronoun
is z
hey I'm rabbit genderqueer tax attorney
I identify as Jennifer Aniston
kidding
remember
DF actually Chinese Mexican a gender
intersex my pronoun is they okay
actually I would want her to watch it
with me there so I can tell her how
crazy these people are and what to stay
away from because it's yeah I wouldn't
want her to watch stuff like this on her
own I wouldn't want her to like be
scrolling on social media and stuff like
this pops up until I have been able to
educate her properly about it
what's important I think it's important
for parents to not expose their kids
themselves to things like this instead
of the kids because the kids are going
to be exposed to it at some point right
so it's better for us to do it and show
that way and should not we're not trying
to like say
um these are demons or whatever now
we're not trying to like demonize people
but we're just trying to show them the
parts that they shouldn't take it's as
simple as that even because because a
lot of I think a lot of parents got like
Bamboozled because they didn't know what
their kids were watching this happened
to my sister my sister is a big liberal
even though both of my parents are
conservative she's proud it's so sad
especially out of colored hair yes
yes I know I know we were from the same
household isn't that crazy wow yeah yeah
she um I brought her on a stream with
sneaka we tried to fix her yeah
um because she's um yeah she's super
like liberal like she she thinks that
the drag show stuff is okay yeah but
it's because
um one there were adults around her
pushing this stuff and also like the
media like when you think about it the
average teenager spends like seven or
eight hours a day on their phones and I
was thinking about this King like media
is the real world when you think about
it like people will say oh that's social
media it's not real but it's like if
we're spending seven or eight hours a
day on social media and I think that's
like the average person is between five
and eight it is the real world because
that's what we're seeing so it's
regardless or not or if it's actually
real in the world the perception is that
it is and a lot of people live more of
their life on their phone than in real
life and so for my sister in that case
even though she had two conservative
parents I would never before that that
she ends up a raging liberal because she
had this stupid horse trainer that was
super liberal and in the school they
showed her CNN kids and this was in
Catholic school they showed her CNN and
then on top of that the media is all
liberal so then she comes out with
colored hair and she has 18 tattoos at
18. yeah but you see this is why it's
important to be very careful the kind of
people you let into your children's
lives to teach them anything yeah you
have to parents have to vet a lot of
these things yeah no there is definitely
plus the bigger family the bigger the
family you have the more the higher the
probability that two one of your kids
are gonna yeah yeah I know it's like it
happened to the best of them
she's cool though I like I like that
sister we get along but I'm just like
how could you how could you do this but
it's funny maybe a closeted Libro what
maybe you're a closeted liberal
who is a closeted liberal all these
reaction channels fake news media the
the fake news reaction channels
is it okay if I ask a few questions
[Music]
uh when a person is born with what is
typically perceived as both male and
female sex workers oh yeah uh what um
ASAP assigned female at Birth when your
parents decide your gender without
considering how you may identify in the
future
[Music]
when your parents identify your gender
without considering how you might
identify in the future what clown world
are we living in oh my gosh okay and
what what's the whole um pronoun thing
when we talk about DX we say ask them if
they would like
but there's only one of them her them
[__] I have no idea what I'm doing
go again
okay go get it
haram I just can you imagine living in a
world where it's acceptable to be so
self-centered that everyone has to ask
you your pronouns and your gender
instead of and that you're so
self-centered that you need to confuse
everybody with these like androgynous
clothes and like dressing like a man and
dressing like a woman and then it's
offensive if anyone gets it wrong like
you know narcissistic you have to be
it's narcissism in my eyes but let me
know what you guys think also I'm
playing around with like making this a
common thing where we just go through
the Twitter Madness every day because
Twitter I can't believe that app is free
shout out Elon Musk you know
um let me know what you guys think in
the comments um like the video on your
way out uh King say bye to the people
bye people like the video on your way
out subscribe to this Channel and sign
up for our Google forms for um to be
notified when we do meet and greets and
I'll talk to you next time